I don't know if you agree with us
because I don't see this I don't see it
as right versus left I don't see I don't
see us I mean obviously we have a
progressive view point there is no
question about that and but at the same
time half hour traffic is coming from
non politics and half hour traffic is
coming from our other verticals you know
media busyness entertainment leaving and
so as a result people are coming to the
Huffington Post who are not necessarily
progressive who don't necessarily share
point of view but who will discover us
and discover a point of view and I'm
very excited about that because I never
wanted just to talk to the choir just to
talk to the people who are grieve with
us I wanted to sort of expand our reach
and and expose many more people to our
viewpoint our intention is to continue
growing in the direction of being an
Internet newspaper and that's why we've
added the new verticals and we're going
to be adding more including sports
international and green and books
another thought about that now and right
now we're very excited about plowing
more money into it and expanding